you know what else is undermining
american life uh is the is the
generalized left-wing take on race so
colin kaepernick is just
a giant con man like one of the great
con men of our time he's a failed nfl
quarterback he had like a couple of good
seasons and then he started to fail and
so they benched him for the immortal
blaine gabbard
and then he decided it's time to kneel
for the national anthem because america
is deeply racist it wasn't racist until
he got benched then he got benched and
then america magically became racist and
he was wearing socks with pigs as cops
on them
on the basis of the lie that the police
are systemically shooting black people
for no reason
this is one of the accolades he got a
nike deal the only failed quarterback to
win a giant nike deal
right with slogans saying things like
you have to risk everything
well he's risked nothing he risked zero
things he waited until he was a backup
quarterback then he knelt for the
national anthem and then the entire left
wing ran to his defense and then he
spent the last few years saying he wants
to play in the nfl while avoiding
anything that would actually get him
back into the nfl because it turns out
he kind of sucks he's not a very good
quarterback okay so now
netflix remember you're a corporate
the way the corporations work is that if
you work for southwest and you say let's
go brandon's a fireable offense but all
of netflix well netflix will just churn
out democratic propaganda day after day
after day
they'll put out propaganda with a p
buddha judge documentary about how he
changed the world and now we've got anna
duvernay who of course is is the woman
who has made other propaganda films
about race in the united states now
she's making a propaganda film with
colin kaepernick
talking about how colin kaepernick
changed the world it's called colin in
black and white
here's a clip from it
you want to know what ruins the country
this kind of crap so here is colin
kaepernick talking about how the nfl
combine
which is a place where players show up
to demonstrate their skills in front of
coaches
so that they will get drafted higher and
be paid more millions of dollars
he compares this
millionaire colin kaepernick
compares this
to slave auctions
in this film
backed by netflix backed by corporate
bucks
but that's that's not a problem let's go
brandon is a problem you know she's more
vulgar in the broader sense of the world
not not a question here's colin
kaepernick doing something morally
despicable but he's fond of doing that
for cash
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you searching for any
defect that might affect your
performance no boundary respected
no dignity left intact
[Music]
okay and then if you can't see this
there's a bunch of guys who are getting
checked out at the combine with their
shirts off
and then they walk out of the combine
and into a graphic of them with chains
on them being auctioned off as slaves
[Music]
i'm not kidding this is what netflix is
producing and people bidding on them
okay i can spot a few differences one
slaves were called slaves because they
were not paid because they were
literally enslaved not they volunteered
into an nfl combine where they then got
paid millions of dollars based on their
physical abilities
but colin kaepernick conflates the two
which is more vulgar for the united
states saying that the nfl combine is
equivalent to actual honest-to-god
slavery or saying let's go brandon
but you're not the real vulgarity is
it's not that that's not real vulgarity
in sports the real vulgarity is that
donald trump went to a braves game and
did the tomahawk chop that was the end
of the world over the weekend
donald trump went to a bravest game by
the way there's great irony to the fact
that texas and georgia are the two
states competing in the world series
after the mlb decided to cave to the
woke scolds
so donald trump went to uh went to the
braves game and he was doing the
tomahawk chop and this was the end of
the world okay because the tomahawk chop
is supposedly racist now if you're going
to talk about which is more racially
problematic comparing the nfl combine to
actual honest god slavery or a
non-offensive symbol at a braves game
where nobody is saying i hate native
americans therefore i'm doing the
tomahawk chop they are saying that this
is a symbol of native american culture
that we wish to co-opt because it's
awesome and they're doing the tomahawk
job
but donald trump is the real threat to
american to american moires that's he's
the threat he's the threat
and the grift is so unbelievably strong
and this is why americans are rebelling
against this kind of crap let's go
brandon is going to become more
ubiquitous not less because it's not
just that joe biden is pursuing radical
economic policy it's that joe biden is
pursuing radical social policy is that
he is bought into
a vulgarization of the idea of america
broad scale and if you note that using
any language whatsoever this makes you
bad if you note that using euphemistic
language because you don't even want to
curse
that's apparently super duper bad
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed